翻訳: Akira Kurazumi
校正: Maki Sugimoto
私はこういうプレゼンテーションを
英語でもしたことないのに
なぜか今日 深い事
「世界観」について
日本語で話すことにした
頑張る
（拍手）
私は典型的なアメリカの田舎者です
大学まで本当の魚と米は
一回も食べたことがなかった
初めて飛行機に乗ったのは
大学を卒業した後です
だから23歳の時 日本に来て
全然日本のこと 知らんかったです
しかも日本語を勉強する
気は全くなかった
彼氏は「日本語 勉強せんと
いけんやん」と言ったんだけど
私は「いや 日本に住むことだけで
なんとかなるさ」と言った
日本に来て４か月 経った頃に
ホームステイ先から自分の
マンションに引っ越すことになった
日本に住んでるから
日本人っぽく洗剤を買って
引っ越しの挨拶をしに
行こうかなと思った
隣にトントンしたら
中から声が聞こえてきた
「誰ですか？」
わぁ しまった
一生懸命その大事なフレーズ
「つまらないものですが」を練習したけど
こういう質問に
答えられんかったなあ
しばらく考えた後
「外人です」って答えた
（笑）
笑いながら出てきてくれて
洗剤を渡した後
彼氏の家に戻ってすぐ
英語の「neighber（隣人）」
と言う単語を調べた
多分 その日初めて やっぱり
日本語 勉強せんといけんなと思った
その時の自分はこんな感じだった
日本のフレームを掛けてたけど
何も見えてなかったです
けど その日から一生懸命
日本語を勉強し始めた
2005年に日本語能力
試験の一級を取った
よし 言葉のレンズが入ったぞ
少し日本の事が見えてきた
同時に日本の文化に馴染もうとした
子供を３人とも日本の
産婦人科で産んだし
日本の学校に行かせた
そして 日本について本も書いた
よし 日本について本も書いたから
専門家になったばい
文化のレンズも入れましょう
言葉と文化のレンズは
しっかり入っているから
日本の全てが見えていると思った
けど 実は一年半くらい前に
あんまり見えていないことに気づいた
その時 親友の満貴子さんに出会った
彼女と私の違いはマジ半端ない
満貴子は仏教を信じている京都人
私はキリスト教を信じている
アメリカの田舎者
共通点が全く無いけど
何とかそれを乗り越えて
すごく仲良い友達になった
なのに よく文化の事でぶつかった
育児とか食事
「どうして私は
日本の文化を知ってるはずが
こんなに満貴子とぶつかると？」
って すごく不思議に思った
でも ある日その答えが来た
満貴子は一所懸命
キリスト教を勉強し始めた
何故かというと 私が大好きだから
私が大事にしている事を知りたくて
たまらんかったからです
一緒に教会に行ったり
図書館から本を借りたり
必死に勉強した
凄く嬉しかったけど
ある日 人生を
変えてしまうような事に気付いた
私には同じような心が無かったです
私は満貴子が大事にしている事に
全然興味がなかった
深く反省して 決心した
それから一緒に
神社と寺に行ったり
夜中まで日本の歴史について
話したりした
けど 私の人生に一番大きな
インパクトがあったのは
一緒に料理をするようになった事です
私がどんだけ料理が嫌いだったか
誰もが知ってる
もう 有名
だから昔からの友達に
「私 料理習ってるぞ」って言ったら
みんな本当に気絶しそうになった
（笑）
正直 私はあんまり興味がなかった
満貴子は料理が大好きだったから
一緒にやりたかっただけです
でも 少しずつ出来るようになって
去年 初めて味噌汁を
作れるようになった
ウケるやろ？
（拍手）
16年間 日本に住んでるけど
去年までは味噌汁は
作れなかった
インスタントのやつを
ずーっと飲みよった
（笑）
で 料理をしながら
日本の食文化について深く話していた
その会話を通して凄く
大事なことに気付いた
今まで日本の文化の表面しか
見えてなかったです
その深い所 理解しづらい所とか
納得いかないところ
それを全然 理解しようとしなかったです
でもね それは一番 大事な所
それは日本の心
それは日本の「世界観」です
で「世界観」って一体なんやろう？
あまり日常生活に出てくるような
単語じゃなかろ？
多分 この部屋に人生に一回も
「世界観」って言ったことない人が
居るかもしれない
じゃあ 皆さん一緒に言いましょうか
せーの
（観客）「世界観」
はい 人生に一回 言ったことがある
（笑）
簡単に言うと「世界観」とは
人間がどういう目で
この世界を見るかという事です
人間の行動と価値観
そして国の文化は
全部「世界観」からきている
でも もしかしたら「文化」と
「世界観」の違いが
あんまり判らないと思っている人が
居るかもしれないから
もっと説明します
家に例えると 文化は
その家の見える部分
屋根 壁 家具とか
でも その下には見えない土台があります
それは「世界観」
この「世界観」の土台がないと
家を建てることができません
もう一つの例を挙げましょう
日本人は赤ちゃんと
一緒に寝る習慣がある
それは「文化」
でも なぜ赤ちゃんと一緒に寝ると？
なんでアメリカ人は一緒に寝ないと？
それは「世界観」
その「世界観」の
「なぜ？」が解らないと
「文化」の「何？」を
理解することができません
私が気付いたのは今までの
眼鏡の掛け方が間違えとった
ここは言葉と文化じゃなくて
ここに言葉も文化も入っている
で 左目に入れなきゃいけない
このレンズは「世界観」
「世界観」のレンズを
右に入れなきゃいけない
「世界観」のレンズが入っていないと
全て見えることはありません
じゃあ 食べ物の話に戻りましょう
去年の５月に友達と
一緒に運動会に行った
そこで私はおにぎりを
三分の一くらい残した
食べたほうが良いって
分かってたけど
でも まあ要らんから
いいやんと思ったけど
友達は相当 嫌な顔をしていた
家に戻った後 その残された
おにぎりについて
１時間 フェイスブックの
やり取りしてたよ
１時間
（笑）
で こういう事を言われた
「アンちゃん 罪悪感ないの？」
「食べ物大事にしないの？」
すごい不思議に思った
「なんでこのおにぎりについて
こういう重い話になってると？
意味が解らない」と思った
けどね その意味が
解らなかったのは
日本の食文化の「世界観」が
理解できなかったからです
じゃあ「いただきます」
という単語を考えましょう
食べる前に「いただきます」
と言うのは日本の文化
それは私は分かってた
けど なぜ「いただきます」
って言うの？
それは日本の「世界観」
それがずーっと分らんかったから
「いただきます」を「Let's eat」
「食べましょう」という風に訳した
でも考えて
「いただきます」は
「Let's eat」じゃなかろ？
「命を頂きます」
命を捧げてくれた動物と植物に
ありがとうって気持ちを
表す表現です
でも それだけじゃなくて
食べ物を作った人
獲った人 運んだ人
そして調理してくれた人に
感謝の気持ちを表す
つまり食べ物のプロセスの
最初の段階から
自分の食卓に載るまで
皆の協力で 皆の努力で
食べる権利があるぞ
大事にしなきゃいけないよ
おにぎり残したらダメよ
っていうことは
全部「いただきます」の
意味に入っている
（拍手）
それは私ずーっと解らんかった
だから正直に言うと
食べ物を大事にする
人間じゃなかった
適当に買って 適当に作って
適当に捨てた
けど 変わった
私と日本人の「世界観」は
同じじゃない
けど 食べ物を大事にするのは
どんな「世界観」でも
どんな考えでも
良いことだと思います
こう思うようになったら
食べ物との関係が変わった
今まで好き嫌いが
半端なかったアンちゃんは
何でも食べるようになった
今まで魚が大嫌いだった私は
捌けるようになったばい
（笑）（拍手）
今まで味噌汁さえ作れなかった私は
去年 おせち料理を作れた
凄かろ？
（拍手）
でも 一番素晴らしいことは
25年間 戦ってきた
摂食障害を克服した
（拍手）
なぜ この一年間だけで
こんなに成長が出来たと？
日本の「世界観」を
理解しようとする—
心が生まれたからです
皆さんに言いたいことがある
もしかしたら外国語を
勉強しているかもしれない
もしかしたら海外に
行く機会があるかもしれない
言葉と文化を理解する事だけで
満足しないで下さい
それよりも深い所 「世界観」を
理解しようとしたら
人生は豊かになります
けどね 日本から出なくてもいいんですよ
自分の周りに「世界観」と考え方が
違う人に囲まれている
上司 友達 同僚
お母さん 奥さん 子供
働いている人は
自分の上司の考え方を
理解しようとしていますか？
旦那さんは 奥さんが大事に
している事が分かりますか？
それか 考え方が違いすぎるから
理解せずに諦めてしまうんですか？
私はこのプレゼンテーションの
準備をしている間に
凄くショッキングな事に気付いた
私は日本の「世界観」を
一生懸命 理解しようとしたけど
自分の反抗中の娘を
理解しようと全然しなかったです
彼女が大事にしている事に
全然興味がなかった
改めて反省して 決心した
これから彼女が大事にしている事を
理解しようとする
そして もっと一緒の時間を
過ごしてあげたり
話を聞いてあげたりする
あなたの周りに
同じような人がいるかどうか
考えてみてください
人間は成長するために
こういう反省するような心が
すごく大事です
私の好きな言葉は
エリック・バーンさんの名言
「他人と過去を変えられないけど
自分と将来を変えられる」
この言葉を考えながら
成長を求めて
お互いを理解しようとする
人間になりましょう
ありがとうございます
（拍手）